this is Justin hey Walt reading Peter
Browns final review for doom on Nintendo
switch there was a time when the thought
of playing a game like 2016 s doom on
Nintendo switch seemed too good to be
true yet here we are playing do on
switch and while it's no doubt
impressive to see it running on a
portable system Nintendo's convertible
console can't stand up to the
performance of other consoles or pcs
doom has endured a few compromises
during its transition to a more modest
platform depending on your tolerance for
blurry visuals and fiddly controls these
cut corners may be a deal-breaker no
matter how fascinating the experience is
at first blush
[Music]
one thing is certain however dooms
campaign is all here accompanied by the
leaderboard centric arcade mode just
like before you push through hordes of
demons with bullets and gut-wrenching
melee takedowns while a heavy metal
soundtrack encourages you to go faster
to hit harder
[Applause]
as enemies scale your weaponry follows
offering a gratifying escalation of
excitement befitting dooms reputation
this is not to say that dooms campaign
was perfect to begin with and the same
issues it had in the past persist here
there's a fair amount of repetition to
deal with some of which diminishes what
should be a monumental milestone landing
on the ground and hell you wind up going
to and fro multiple times and despite
the feverish action that carries you
along the way there's an amount of deja
vu to contend with that saps your
enthusiasm if ever so slightly
ultimately dooms fast-paced combat makes
the occasionally repetitive journey
worth taking and the addition of arcade
mode allows you to focus on action alone
if you have little interest in the game
so so narrative or mission structure the
mode was introduced on other platforms
in a post release update and is designed
for people who want to either practice
their speed running skills or rank on
internet leaderboards multipliers and
other score boosting elements have been
introduced to encourage different
tactics and in some cases to create an
unlikely path around a map for optimal
scores and efficiency
every stage of the campaign is unlocked
in arcade mode from the start and you're
allowed to pick and choose from weapons
that would normally be unavailable in
addition to every room perk when
choosing your loadout the freedom to hop
back and forth throughout the game is a
boon as a returning player though it's
constructed in such a way that you might
want to dip your toes in the campaign
from the start to get your bearings
unless you're able to find the rare
extra lives amidst all the chaos one
death is all it takes for your run to
end an arcade mode
you may also want to forego playing
handheld at all one of the unfortunate
realities of playing such a demanding
game with switched icons is that you're
bound by the limitations of small analog
sticks doom offers sensitivity and
camera smoothing adjustments that do
help to a degree but compared to playing
on the full-sized pro controller joy
Khan's feel noticeably less reliable and
despite the options menu hinting it
motion controls when docked they don't
apply to aiming you just waggled the
right joique on to melee enemies
switches screen can also prove
problematic when facing a room of
sprinting demon it may just be too small
to provide the encompassing experience
the game's toughest challenges demand
it's also strange to see the UI as it is
with a font size so small that you'll be
hard-pressed to quickly read menus when
playing on docks none of this is to say
that doom is unplayable or unenjoyable
on the go but it's definitely the least
optimal way to play no matter how you
approach playing doom on switch you'll
undoubtedly have to contend with blurry
visuals Bethesda has promised the game
will run at 720p regardless of whether
your switches docked or not in practice
even if the game is outputting a 720p
signal there are frequent instances when
the game shifts into lower gear
presenting not only low-res textures and
models but an overall muddied image that
indicates dynamic resolution switching
there are rare moments when doom will
appear sharp and clear but be prepared
to face drastic swings in quality
including plenty of disappointing haze
[Music]
Viper's this is most apparent during
multiplayer matches where large groups
of players on screen caused the
resolution to plummet and expect FPS
dips and maps that contain a lot of
geometry and lighting effects even so
it's easy to jump into a few matches and
get some enjoyment out of dooms
multiplayer it maintains the game's
emphasis on speed and firepower and
presentation issues aside performs just
as well as you'd hope when it comes to
matchmaking and match stability with
plenty of modes and unlockables to
tinker with there's plenty to keep you
busy if you need a break from the
campaign if you can stand to look at a
lesser version of Doom's once
captivating world you'll find that the
game plays well enough on switch so long
as you've got a TV in front of you and a
pro controller at hand there's nothing
else like it on a portable system but be
prepared to face of a handful of
compromises especially if you're used to
playing on other platforms it's an
impressive port that begs you to
consider gameplay over graphics and it
succeeds more often than not you need to
remove each lens individually carefully
release the hinges
[Music]
[Music]